existential flexibility is not like the
normal flexibility the day-to-day that
you need to do work it is um
it is a a business's ability to make
profound
180 degree strategic shift
in order to advance
that just cause
um
i think one of the single best examples
of what an existential flex looks like
happened back in the late 70s early 80s
so i mentioned apple and steve jobs
steve jobs had this vision of empowering
individuals to stand up to big brother
he saw
the personal computer as the perfect
technology to do that
and
the jobs in apple had was already a big
company ready fast growing company one
of the first unicorns
they'd already had success from the
apple one the apple ii jobs was already
famous and as is the practice of a lot
of executives they went and visited
other companies and jobs and a few of
his senior guys went on a tour of xerox
park out in menlo park
and xerox showed them a new technology
that they had invented called the
graphic user interface
which allowed people to use a computer
by clicking on a mouse
and moving a cursor across a desktop
um
and jobs looked at this new technology
that they didn't invent
and said this is profound because right
now if you want to use a computer you
have to learn how to
you know you have to learn a basic code
right which means a very small
percentage of the population can
actually use it and if my ambition is to
empower as many individuals as possible
then this graphic user interface is
something i have no choice
to advance my cause it's obvious that we
have to invest in it
and so he said to his ex senior
executives who are with him we're going
to invest in this graphic user interface
thing
and one of them
let's call him the voice of reason
uh said steve we can't
we we cannot invest in this we've
already invested millions of dollars and
countless man hours in a completely
different strategic direction uh if we
take that money away and reinvest it in
this graphic user interface thing we're
going to blow up our own business
to which jobs actually said better we
should blow it up than someone else
and that decision led to the macintosh
the macintosh so profoundly changed the
course of
computing that the entire software of
windows is designed to act like a
macintosh and the reason a computer is
now a household appliance
uh
is because of that decision
and they did take a short term loss and
they did take a hit
because that's what happens
necessarily when you reinvest
but that's an existential flex profound
strategic shift in order to advance your
cause